figaro live 19h07 on se retrouve ce soir
en cette fin de semaine pour tester l'un
des derniers arrivés de ces dernières
semaines la ps1 qui est enfin sorti
après des mois d'attentes pour de
nombreux joueurs et après un autre test
il y à quelques jours de la xbox series
x que nous avions pu tester du côté de
microsoft cette fois ci on va du côté de
son concurrent sony qui vient de sortir
est bien là ps 5 alors quelles sont ses
capacités quels sont les jeux
disponibles quelles sont les nouveautés
également que l'on peut trouver à
travers cette nouvelle console on va
répondre à toutes ces questions avec
vous en direct que ce soit sur la page
principale du figaro sur youtube mais
également sur twitch pour cela et bien
on remercie chloé boîtier qui est de
nouveau présente avec nous qui nous a
permis et bien déjà de tester la xbox et
reese est désormais la ps 5 et donc on
va découvrir tout cela avec vous vous
avez déjà pu mettre la main dessus et
essayer l'ensemble du panel qu'elle
propose à ce jour
n'hésitez pas à commenter à nous poser
vos questions à réagir peut-être que
vous l'avez déjà peut-être que vous avez
l'intention de vous la procurer en cette
approche des fêtes de noël on verra si
cela est possible et je crois savoir
spoiler alert que c'est un peu compliqué
merci en tout cas à vous d'être avec
nous bonsoir abraham couleurs sur
youtube
merci à vous qui nous rejoignent un
merci goal of god bless me kyi
le a rejoint également sur youtube on
est en direct et on interagit avec vous
donc n'hésitez pas à en prendre à vos
commentaires et vos questions en
priorité ce sera avec grand plaisir
cette console chloé vient de sortir il
ya un peu plus d'une semaine une dizaine
de jours elle est un petit peu plus cher
que son que sa concurrente
enfin quel est son prix en vote alors
elle est au même prix que la xbox et
reese x elle est à 500 euros pour la
version à la version avec le lecteur de
blu-ray donc la voilà la voici la voilà
donc la version avec lecteur de blu ray
est à 500 euros dans ce qui est
directement le même prix que la xbox
série 6 par contre si vous estimez que
vous n'avez pas besoin de lecteurs
debouverie et que vous allez acheter vos
jeux entièrement en ligne entièrement en
version dématérialisée la la console
coûte 400 euros ce qui était le prix de
lancement de la playstation 4 en 2013
après bon il faut bien savoir ce qu'on
fait quand on décide de prendre une
version totalement digital ça veut dire
que vous allez devoir acheter vos jeux
uniquement sur le playstation store
donc vous allez être dépendant de la
politique de prix de sony est souvent on
sait que les jeux qui sortent dans le
commerce au tout début
ils sont quand même moins cher dans la
grande distribution que directement sur
le playstation store
donc même si à 100 euros d'écart je
pense que surtout si vous aimez acheter
vos jeux dès la sortie c'est plus
intéressant sur le long terme de prendre
la version à 500 euros parce que vous
allez
la différence de prix va être très très
vite compensés par les économies que
vous allez faire en achetant vos jeux
plutôt à 60 euros qu'à 70 en les
achetant du côté de la grande
distribution du côté de l'e commerce etc
plutôt que de passer directement par le
playstation store
après je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya jamais de
sol sur le playstation store si on a
quand même assez régulièrement mais sur
le démarrage des jeux vraiment quand ils
sont sortis ils sortent à 70 euros sur
le psn
vous les trouvez à 60 voire des x 50
voire des x 45 dans le dans le commerce
donc c'est une dimension à prendre en
compte merci à vous d'être avec nous on
vous salue sur youtube notamment
bonsoir sérénité elles m'ont janot
mailly michael thiery nat rev à merci
d'être avec nous merci pour vos
salutations n'hésitez pas à commenter à
nous dire bien ce que vous pensez de
cette console peut être que vous l'avez
déjà peut-être que vous souhaitez avoir
peut-être que vous visez plutôt sa
concurrente du côté de microsoft on
prend vos commentaires avec grand
plaisir on peut même les faire
apparaître à l'écran grâce à la
réalisation de julien qu'une aile qu'on
remercie
voilà on est avec vous pour tester et
bien les différents jeux coffre d'ores
et déjà cette console justement en
parlant des jeux chloé keil et le panel
d'ores et déjà disponible alors le panel
est quand même beaucoup plus large et
plus intéressant que sur xbox à d'accord
parce que bell c'était le problème de la
xbox et que ça manquait un peu de jeu de
gros jeux de lancement alors que là on
est quand même plutôt bien servi du côté
de saunier donc la part d'un blabla
c'est à peu près la seule exclusivité
playstation 5 mais purement playstation
5c demon soul ce qui est un remastered
un jeu qui était sorti en 2009 si je ne
dis pas de bêtises qui était sorti sur
playstation 3 qui a eu un succès
d'estimé mais pas qui était pas non plus
un grand succès commercial est en fait
c'est à dire avec le temps
ce sont les gens qui ont fait des dark
souls donc des jeux qui ont une grande
renommée pour leurs difficultés
et ben voilà il ya eu ils se sont dit
allez on va refaire damon soldes on va
leur faire un peu à la sauce playstation
second c'est à dire en cas de cas 60 fps
super beau super jolie par contre
toujours aussi difficile mais voilà
c'est un peu le jeu vitrine de ce
lancement mais il ya aussi un autre jeu
beaucoup plus accessible qui est spider
man miles morales donc lui est également
disponible sur playstation 4
donc ça c'est pas une pure exclusivité
ps 5 mais c'est une exclusivité sony est
donc passé c'est la suite directe du
playstation du pardon du spider man qui
était sorti en 2018
c'est un add-on qui est voilà qui fait
une dizaine d'heures de jeu à peu près
donc c'est pas non plus un jeu très très
long mais qui est quand même super
agréable sinon dans les autres les
autres je vous avais de côté plutôt
famille enfants vous avez sackboy big
adventure donc là qui est un jeu de
plateforme voilà jeu de plates-formes
leur littlebigplanet exactement donc ça
c'est plutôt axé famille et vous avez
aussi l'or qui est inclus dans la
console et qui est en jeu vachement bien
que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle à
strauss playroom donc en état de
commencer par celui là d'accord et c'est
un jeu qui à la base est une démo
technique pour montrer toutes les
capacités de la nouvelle manette alors
je vais la mettre là voilà de la
nouvelle manette de la playstation 5
donc c'est une manette qui s'appelle non
plus dualshock mais dual sense donc vous
hanter à la différence sémantique à la
noce ans ce n'est pas innocent en fait
la dualshock ans grosso modo c'était une
manette qui j brand la cdu à 100 donc
ils veulent faire une manette qui va
plutôt vous donner des sensations et en
fait les vibrations sont beaucoup plus
fines sont mois en bourrinant va dire et
elles vont essayer de reproduire des
sensations réelles donc pour le dire
clairement dans astro ce playroom
parlant quand vous allez marcher sous la
pluie vous allez ressentir des
vibrations dans la manette donne
l'impression que vous êtes sous la pluie
quand c'est la grêle vous allez sentir
que c'est quand même plus fort quand
vous marchez dans le sable vous allez
leur sentir qu'on va être dans la boue
voulait aussi avoir des voix toutes les
vibrations sont
donne l'impression fait-on creux de
votre main de ressentir toutes ses
sensations et c'est vachement bien et
vous avez aussi sur cette manne est une
autre autre chose c'est les gâchettes
voilà les gâchettes qui sont ici donc là
vous voyez bon jeu les j'appuie dessus
sans problème mais selon les jeux en
fait les gâchettes pourront plus ou
moins résisté et elle vibreront en même
temps donc ça vous donnera par exemple
si vous tir à l'arc
vous allez sentir la corde qui ce temps
vous allez sentir la tension est dans le
jeu que je vais vous montrer il ya plein
d'endroits il faut tirer sur des
ressorts et donc vous avez parlé vous
allez sentir la résistance d'accord donc
c'est un cinglé c'est un geek qui est
pas mal et donc j'espère qu'il sera
exploité dans le futur par les
développeurs parce que sur les autres
jeux de lancement c'est pas vraiment le
cas on espère parce que déjà sur la
manette de ps 4 qui était proposé
certaines fonctionnalités comme une
lumière qui s'adaptait selon jeu avec un
interphone ainsi qu'yves inquiéter
spéciale au jeu mais qui était pas
forcément exploité par par tous les jeux
disponibles
bah là on a aussi le retour d'un une
chose qu'ils avaient sur la manne de la
baisse cette ps4 c'est cette zone ici
qui est tactile
toute la zone ici est active et ça
devait être beaucoup utilisé sur la ps4
finalement ça a été très peu utilisé on
maintenant s'en servent surtout basse et
pour appuyer ici et là on voit ça ouvre
des options mais le fait de vraiment
glisser son doigt sur cette zone là en
fait c'est assez peu utilisé mais en
tout cas bon ça fait sur le pavé tactile
fait son retour il est toujours là merci
en tout cas de vos commentaires sur
youtube
bonsoir baba bonsoir ce qui le dos
également
edmond
daftine j'espère ne pas écorcher votre
nom baba qui nous dit que le et la
nouvelle génération manque de gros jeux
de lancement demon soul et un remastered
inaccessibles au commun des mortels
c'est vrai que c'est un jeu très peu
accessible il va falloir se pencher
plutôt vers vers spider man ah oui pour
damas si vous voulez de données
accessible oui ça et spider man après
quand on regarde les catalogues de
lancement de la playstation 2 d'apple
iphone 3 de la playstation 4 il ya
franchement y'a pas photo c'est vraiment
ce line up de lancement qui est le
meilleur
alors avant de se pencher vers astro est
le jeu qui est en train de tourner on a
une question d'edmond davtyan qui nous
demande si on peut encore chauffer la ps
5 questions compliquées vous à l'état
que l'étudiant vous allez être déçus en
fait oui c'est possible
c'est possible mais c'est difficile en
fait alors qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya
eu très peu de stock ou lancement enfin
en tout cas tout le stock de lancement
était prêt réservé depuis des mois
depuis le mois de septembre depuis le
lancement des pré réservations
tout est parti très vite et c'est
tellement partie très vite qu'il ya
certains revendeurs qui ont pris plus de
réservations que de stocks qu'il
n'aurait eu au moins 2 au mois de
novembre
donc certaines personnes qui ont réservé
en septembre ou en octobre fait n'auront
pas leur console avant le mois de
décembre à fraisses maintenant
maintenant qu'on est le lancement est
passé il y a des réassorts mais les
réassorts sont faibles même s'il ya des
vagues assez assez régulière qui
arrivait en fait la plupart des
nouvelles vagues de livraison ce sera
pour le 14 décembre
c'est ce qu'on a vu passer comme date
sous les différents revendeurs vrai
c'est que bas il ya tellement de
demandes que dès que la fnac carrefour
met ou littéralement cet essai discount
met en vente
vous plaidez playstation 5 le bruit
court très très vite sur les réseaux
sociaux est généralement dans la minute
il n'y a plus rien donc si vous voulez
absolument une playstation 5
je vous recommande de suivre des comptes
twitter notamment hannstar joueurs qui
sont vraiment ou deal labs qui sont
vraiment au taquet sur cette question
problème c'est qu'ils sont tellement
suivi que bad et qu'ils disent
il ya de la playstation 5 disponible sur
tel site généralement tout part dans la
seconde mais perdait pas espoir même si
ça va être très compliqué et si vous ne
voulez pas faire si vous êtes prêts à
attendre je vous conseille d'attendre
plus tôt début 2021 pour vous lancer
dans la chasse à la playstation 5 parce
que là ça s'annonce quand même ardue pas
impossible mais ardu et de ce que nous
ont dit sony bon la situation risque
d'être compliqué au moins jusqu'au mois
de mars
et c'est ce qu'on avait déjà dit lors de
notre test de la xbox série x inutile
non plus de vous presser haut
enfin de vous presser auprès des
revendeurs qui peuvent les vendre à des
prix beaucoup plus cher ah ouais non
mais surtout ne faites pas cette erreur
ne n'achetez pas des consoles
allez au double de leur prix à 800 euros
700 euros 1000 euros 1200 euros ne
faites pas cette erreur en fin fin déjà
fin vous nourrissez un système qui est
juste un peu un peu un petit peu
détestable donc donc ne fait pas ça et
et attend dévoilé de trouver la console
à son prix normal qui est de 500 euros
je le rappelle puis c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant parce qu'on est sur la
première sortie je pense que l'eau et où
on n'a pas vu d'image de personnes
faisant la queue pendant une nuit
entière devant un magasin de revente
pour se procurer une nouvelle console
qui vient de sortir on a l'habitude de
voir ça avec la sortie d iphone et
souvent avec les consoles qui sortent et
bah forcément un cosy de 19 les que nous
ne serons pas fait mais on voit quand
même que il ya eu tout autant de succès
que d'habitude avec ses ruptures de
stock un peu partout pour se procurer
cette console voilà en tout cas qui
répondent à vos commentaires à vos
questions merci notamment kenan qui nous
dit qu'il faut attendre encore un peu et
c'est bon bah oui tout à fait il va
falloir être patient bonsoir à tim ruben
qui nous rejoint sur youtube
n'hésitez pas on prend vos commentaires
vos questions si vous souhaitez qu'on
les prenne en avance alors oui il faut
répondre à votre question kenan on voit
bien vos messages ne vous inquiétez pas
on a une qui est une question
intéressante
non sans malice de tom peron sur youtube
chloé je dis est ce que sony n'aurait
pas prémédité les ruptures de strasbourg
amplifier la demande ensuite
alors non mais ça c'est aulas a cédé des
idées reçues comme quoi les les ruptures
de stock sont créés sciemment par les
consoliers vous pensez bien que si sony
pouvait vendre toutes les pèse 5 qui
sont demandés par le consommateur il le
ferait il n'hésiterait pas une seule
seconde ce n'est pas dans leur intérêt
qu'il y ait des ruptures de stock sont
les clairement pas il préfère vendre des
consoles
plutôt que de créer genre oh mon dieu en
fait il ya une hype secrètes autour de
la paix ces jeunes 5
non ils préféraient les vendre ses
consoles plutôt que de voir les
consommateurs frustrés de ne pas les
trouver
alors on a une question avant qu'on se
penche vers vers astros on a une
question de dell nous shdm à 29 sur
twitch merci d'être avec nous qui nous
demande s'il est possible de faire
fonctionner des copies de sauvegardes de
jeux sur disque optique
sera-t-il possible d'installer un autre
système d'exploitation et d'exécuter des
programmes fait part des amateurs non
j'imagine que c'est une boîte très
sécurisé c'est une voie très sécurisé on
savait pas faire ce que vous voulez
dessus c'est pas un pc ont donc non non
vous vous pourrez pas faire ça par
contre vous pourrez rajouter des
extensions de saucats pas un disque dur
externe si vous avez besoin de plus de
place sur votre console mais de là à
exécuter des programmes qui ne sont pas
qu'ils ne viennent pas du playstation
store ne rêvez pas c'est pas possible
alors bas on va pouvoir répondre à vos
questions notamment la vôtre lucas
chevrier qui nous demandent si la
manette ps 5 et mieux que celle de ps4
alors vous qui avez testé les 2 qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est mieux que celle de ps4
bah oui parce qu'il ya des meilleurs
vibrations
les vibrations sont vraiment vachement
bien et
et que elle se prend bien elle est un
peu plus lourde forcément parce qu'il ya
plus de choses à l'intérieur donc c'est
beaucoup plus lourd qu'une climat est de
presque 4 heures je sais qu'il ya des
gens qui s'en sont plaint qu'ils
trouvaient que voilà ça fait ton fatigué
un petit peu et c'est vrai qu'elle
penche un peu vers l'avant ce que pas
mal de poids est en fête et sur la vente
de la manette
moi c'est moi pas gêner plus que ça
franchement après oui elle est plus
lourde que pardon si on compare à la
mède la xbox série 6 elle est plus
lourde mais c'est parce que ben il ya
plus de deux choses dedans et notamment
aussi bas la xbox series x la manette
marché avec des pics depuis d'ailleurs
j'ajoute parce que entre temps j'ai fait
mon enquête sur l'exode series x vous
pouvez rajouter une batterie amovible et
celle de la si vous aviez déjà une
batterie amovible pour la xbox one elle
marche parfaitement sur la série x pas
la peine d'en racheter
voilà pour vous répondre
et pour interagir avec vous aussi ce
qu'ils dosent sur youtube merci d'être
avec nous bonsoir jauge de raids qui
nous dit ah je ne suis fait avoir par un
email d'un motif qu'ils parlaient de
l'allocution de macron alors oui c'était
il ya quelques jours j'avais le plaisir
d'animer également sur twitter on fait
beaucoup d'actu mais on fait aussi du
jeu vidéo rester avec nous jauge de
raids ce sera avec plaisir qu'on vous
gardera on a alors toujours des
questions qui continuent de d'arrivée
ben voilà ce qu'il doit on a on a plus
répondre à votre question sur le confort
de la manette qui est en tout cas selon
vous chloé meilleure que celle de la
dualshock là on est sur la duet sense
désormais on à une question sur youtube
de free leur d'arc qui nous dit bonsoir
apparemment tout lé ps -cinq on aurait
des soucis alors est ce que dans
l'actualité il ya eu des retours de
l'acheteur déçu ah bah oui oui mais en
fait alors tout non en gros ce qui se
passe c'est que toutes les playstation 5
ne sont pas égales par rapport au bruit
et aux silences qu'elles sont censées
censées émettre donc là par exemple à la
playstation 5 que j'ai à côté de moi
elle est d'un très silencieuse là en
fait juste pour être prêté l'oreille
pour entendre un petit peu mais par
rapport à la mienne parce que là c'est
pas la mienne c'est pas c'est pas mon
c'est pas ma console à moi la mienne est
beaucoup plus brillantes et samassa m'a
un peu choqué quand je les ai récupérées
alors ce n'est clairement pas le bruit
de vente de vraiment d'aspirateurs que
peut faire la playstation 4 et puis
encore la playstation 4 pro on en est
loin mais on entend une sorte de bruit
de rotation une sorte de petit qui est
pas forcément très agréable surtout au
début quand on se rend compte après on
s'y habitue et surtout le bruit des jeux
en fait tu couvres couvre ce bruit là
mais énormément de consommateurs ont été
surpris surtout que le bruit est plus ou
moins fort en fonction des en fonction
des modèles donc c'est un petit peu la
loterie
pour le moment c'est pas trop comment
est-ce que ça va être reçue au niveau du
sav d'accord sony n'a pas s'est pas
encore vraiment exprimé sur cette
question là donc on attend de voir mais
en tout cas nos confrères des numériques
ont donc le site les numériques ils ont
un petit peu ans qui était là dessus en
fait ils ont ouvert les playstation
qu'ils avaient pour vérifier ce qui se
passait ce qu'ils ont vu c'est que
toutes les consoles n'ont pas les mêmes
ventilateur il y a en fait deux
deux types de ventilateurs deux modèles
d'ordinateurs qui sont utilisés et y en
a un bac y est très silencieux l'autre
qu'il est moi ça se joue à pas beaucoup
non l'entente quand même la différence
et bat malheureusement vous ne pouvez
pas savoir à l'avancé ce qu'est le
ventilateur est installé dans votre
console c'est la loterie c'est la
loterie total et donc oui c'est un petit
peu gênant après c'est pas non plus
catastrophique clairement à ce que je
vois beaucoup de monde qui s'emballe sur
cette question ce n'est pas la
catastrophe un cv ça va pas vous
réveiller la nuit non plus après c'est
peut-être ça peut être un peu gênant si
la console elle est présente dans votre
chambre et que vous la laisser en veille
la nuit gonzalez à 30 ans à un tigre qui
va pas très agréable mais bon un peu
comme quand vous laisser un ordinateur
en veille dans une chambre là vous
entendez comme que ça mouline un petit
peu surtout s'il est pas s'il n'est pas
tout neuf
c'est un peu le même type de bruit mais
mais voilà donc je sais que ça suscite
beaucoup d'inquiétude donc si vraiment
ça vous gêne si vous n'avez pas envie de
prendre le risque
attendez avant d'acheter une playstation
5 je pense que ce genre de problème va
être corrigé dans les prochaines
versions dans les prochains matchs qui
seront qui seront créés donc qui seront
livrés dans les prochains mois donc si
vous voulez pas de prendre de risque à
mon avis des plus sûrs d'attentes va
être l'ami 2021 voilà l'été 2021 pour
être sûr d'avoir des modèles qui seront
un peu plus fiable qui font moins de
bruit entendu c'est bien noté donc voilà
qui qui vous répond on avait une
question également de kenan qui nous
demandait s'il était possible d'aller
sur sur certains jeux sur certaines
applications et en même temps sur
internet et non non non non non en fait
sur cette console
alors déjà il n'y a pas tout ce qui est
critique quick résume donc la capacité
de la xbox série x qui vous permet en
fait de zapper d'un joint à un autre en
fait là c'est pas possible sur la
playstation 4
la playstation 5 vous ne pouvez pas ce
que vous pouvez faire en fait c'est ce
qu'ils disent était déjà avec la 4c
zapper entre un jeu et une application
vidéo donc type youtube netflix ocs
amazon etc
donc ça vous pouvez vous pouvez arrêter
votre parti pour dire ah tiens je vais
regarder un épisode 2
de je ne sais pas quoi un épisode de
série et vous allez reprendre votre
partir immédiatement là vous êtes à
arrêter par contre si vous jouez à
spider man et que vous dites tiens je
vais faire un peu dark de demon's souls
et ben en fait vous allez vous bien
sauvegarder avant parce que ben en fait
le jeu ne va pas garder la console ne va
pas garder en mémoire votre parti de
spider man voulait pas la reprendre
pilar vous êtes arrêté contrairement à
ce que fait la xbox série x et donc
donc voilà là dessus on est on est pas
aussi avancée que microsoft sur ce plan
là d'accord voilà en tout cas merci à
vous pour derrick ou qui nous suivaient
sur tweets sont vos salut merci d'être
avec nous merci aussi pour les infos que
vous nous apportez je vois beaucoup de
questions alors avant de continuer avec
vous dans le chat on va peut-être parler
des jeux que nous voyons défiler alors
juste avant c'était astro quelles sont
les particularités de ce jeu qui est un
petit peu le jeu de lancement pour
montrer un petit peu les capacités de la
console bas attendais pas du coup je
vais remettre à sa mort comme ça va vous
verrez bien que le crise il n'existe pas
hop
donc là je relance astro que j'avais
quitté en pleine partie tout à l'heure
et ben voilà ça va me le relancer depuis
donc la maman le nouvel écran pour
montrer que c'est un jeu fait par sony
donc c'est très inspiré par marvel voilà
donc
hop à ce crime
voilà donc on relance le jeu de pile
depuis le début donc c'est une
c'est donc comme je disais tout à
l'heure c'est une sorte de démo
technique mais une démo technique
vachement bien fait sur les qui va
montrer toutes les capacités de la
console et toutes les capacités de la
manette surtout donc écran tactile le
micro les vibrations les gages et
adaptatives
le fait que vous pouvez aussi souffler
dans le micro pour faire certaines
actions bref ça va vous montrer tout ça
est ce qui est chouette dans ce jeu
c'est que ça exploite à fond
l'histoire de la playstation 1 donc si
vous êtes assez bas voilà vous montre un
peu si vous êtes un peu attaché à 7 à
cette marque
ce qui est chouette dans ce jeu là c'est
que déjà vous allez devoir essayer de
retrouver dans les niveaux
ben les anciennes consoles et leurs
accessoires donc là bon là je suis sur
la playstation playstation 4
là elle a perdu playstation 3 donc avec
la vita l'édition la psp les différentes
versions de la playstation 3 la
playstation 2 l'année mon rôle car la
caméra la playstation de slim et
quelques jeux emblématiques la
playstation 1 dont c'était la psx avec
l'écran ouais bah ouais d'accord voilà
puis à plein de petits limites comme ça
donc ça c'est des items qui se
retrouvent dans les différents niveaux
et à l'intérieur des niveaux en fait il
ya plein de clins d'oeil à
je pars ou licence culte playstation
donc moi ça a fonctionné à fond parce
que ben voila j'ai j'ai eu toutes les
consoles playstation depuis l'a1
donc il ya un effet nostalgie qui marche
totalement en tout cas qui m'a
totalement convaincu et
[Musique]
et donc ouais en fait il ya un petit
côté un peu jeux nintendo dans le sens
on va jouer avec la nostalgie est donc
là je vais vous montrer
vous montrez un nouveau nom temps
l'agent merci au passage
à vous sur youtube sur la page
principale du figaro et sur twitch qui
nous suivaient pas pour vous répondre
kenan si vous souhaitez nous retrouver
sur twitch bien c'est tout simplement un
figaro slash live vous pourrez le
retrouver ont fait régulièrement du
stream sur bien sûr sur l'actu mais
également sur le jeu vidéo donc on vous
donne rendez vous je vois beaucoup de
questions sur les jeux notamment votre
question thriller d'arc on va on va y
revenir en rester avec nous on essaye de
répondre à tout le monde et de parler
aussi de toutes les facettes de cette de
cette de cette console merci à vous
d'être avec nous je vois que vous nous
rejoignez de plus en plus nombreux ça
fait plaisir de vous retrouver
alors on va rapidement abordé la
question de la manette puisque plaît
vous nous expliquer que ce jeu exploite
particulièrement la manette chine mail
merci d'être avec nous sur youtube vous
demander si on a déjà parlé de la duel
sensui justement on a on a déjà abordé
ce thème mais on va y revenir très
rapidement pour vous vous nous dites que
vous avez réussi à le commander le 19
novembre bonne réception
j'espère que vous n'aurez pas de
mauvaise surprise on a aussi tomtom
peron qui nous dit que la manette est
une vraie innovation et par équipes ce
box y songe sérieusement c'est vrai
qu'il ya une différence concrète à ces
fortes entre la manette de la ps1 qu'est
celle de la xbox qui elles fonctionnent
à piles et n'a pas toutes les
fonctionnalités assez des vibrations
classique en fait sur la manette xbox
alors que là ce sont des vibrations
avancé donc soit on va alors si on est
très très précieux on va appeler ça du
retour haptique mais sinon on va appeler
ça des vibrations hd c'est un peu plus
car les vibrations hd voilà donc ils
sont beaucoup plus in
et donc là vous voyez par exemple quand
je disais qu'il ya des clins d'oeil aux
jeux sony voilà c'est un epic fc calais
script le voilà qui était un joli n'est
sorti son incroyable playstation donc
pour eux les plus anciens d'entre nous
reconnaîtrons reconnaîtront cette
licence et là vous voyez par exemple
quand je marche dans l'herbe
donc ça malheureusement à la fin me
croire sur parole mais en fait j'ai été
très légère vibration à gauche droite
gauche droite gauche droite et j'ai
l'impression d'être voilà de marché un
petit peu sur l'herbe en fait je sens
les pas du robot quand je marche
voilà quand je donne des petits coups
comme ça je les sens aussi et là bas et
vous allez avoir des gros nuages qui me
souffle qui me souffle dessus
en fait je sens ma l'appareil je sens le
mécanisme qui tourne dans mes mains je
sens tout ça dans mes mains là en
dessous il ya de la boue ben voilà en
fait je vois c'est très difficile à
décrire le mieux enfin faut vraiment
l'essayer pour comprendre mais je sens
l'impression de la boue je sens que
enfin les petites vibrations très légère
vous voyez en fait sur votre téléphone
portable
si vous n'avez pas désactivé quand vous
appuyez sur le clavier de votre
téléphone ça fait des clips bine bine
bine et bien c'est cette technologie
mais en plus en plus avancées et en plus
précise donc qui est ce qui est assez
agréable et là bas voilà là vous
reconnaissez certainement médiévale
la petite havre il ya eu un remastered
exactement donc ça c'est des trucs un
peu un peu chouette
des vibrations qui bon je le répète
alors ce jeu est mis gratuitement avec
la console dont vous n'avez pas le payer
s'est offert avec la console et c'est un
jeu qui se terminant en cinq heures on
va dire en ligne droite mais par contre
si vous voulez tout collectionner voilà
vous pouvez rajouter encore quelques
heures de plaisir et de jeux dessus
parce que c'est quand même assez long de
tous tout collectionner mais c'est
vraiment enfin chauffe eau pour un jeu
gratuit qui est censé être une démo
technique c'est vraiment une très bonne
surprise entendu c'est bien noté merci à
vous tous d'être d'être avec nous bon
soir h sur youtube vous nous dites pas
la peine de prendre la paix est
maintenant leverage aux excuses ils
n'arriveront pas avant 2022 va merci
votre commentaire chine mais il resté
avec nous on va répondre aux questions
tout de suite
kenan également on va répondre à vos
questions qui nous a rejoints désormais
sur twitch tom peron je prend bien en
main de votre question enfin en clair on
essaie vraiment de vous répondre à tous
restez avec nous passer ce petit moment
de soirée avec nous et on essaye de
répondre à tout le monde on a déjà des
questions on à escalles tech aussi on va
essayer de répondre à votre question on
a une question notamment sur la
compatibilité de la ps4 et de la pnh une
question d'abraham couleurs qui ne
demandent si les joueurs ps 5 et ps4
pourront jouer en ligne
on a chip mais qui nous demande
6 et 2 alors attendez que je retrouve
votre commentaire vous êtes mon amoureux
voilà sur les paramètres multijoueur le
parti fonctionne t-il avec les joueurs
de la ps4
alors on sait que le cros plaît donc ce
système qui permet de jouer entre les
consoles que ce soit par exemple entre
la xbox et la ps4 où la paix est 5 fois
la ps4 en tout cas existent comment ça
se passe entre la ps1 qu'est ce qui te
sort alors c'est une excellente question
je vous avoue jeu
vais pas dire de bêtises parce que je
n'en suis pas sûr je n'ai pas testé
multijoueur mais j'imagine
j'ose imaginer qu'il n'y aura pas de
restriction entre fait sonner n'aime pas
trop le cros play avec les autres
consoles avec le fait que des joueurs
playstation qui joue avec des joueurs
nintendo et des joueurs xbox il aime pas
trop
même s'ils ont cédé pour notamment
fortnight mais de base c'est pas une
idée qui leur plaît il prête avant eux
ils mettent en avant la sécurité disent
non mais non on préfère là on évite de
mélanger tout le monde on préfère que ça
reste sur notre notre système donc
j'imagine que ça posera pas de problème
au sein du psn donc mais ça
malheureusement je peux pas je peux pas
vous répondre
d'autant que ben pendant le la phase de
test la console n'était pas historique
dans le grand public donc voilà enfin il
ya plein de paramètres qu'on pouvait pas
utiliser on n'avait pas le droit de vous
en ligne etc
donc ça je peux je préfère ne pas me
prononcer dessus mais j'imagine que oui
entendu merci à vous d'être avec nous
merci de vos questions bonjour gaspard
dg gauge tamines locaux qui nous a
rejoint et lisse devos
hum hum hum you you i
voilà en tout cas merci à vous d'être
d'être avec nous on a beaucoup de
pression je viens de voir passer une
question pardon c'était marqué autant
garder sa ps4 donc ch qui dit alors
autant garder sa ps4 les charges les
taux de chargement ne valent pas
vraiment le coup alors si enfin même si
ça dépend des jeux aurait des
changements allaient changer un peu le
coup à niveau des charges
on parce que on va donc la playsation 5
permet de lire les jeux playstation 4
way ce qui est bien parce que c'est pas
trop dans l'habitude de sony la
playstation 4 vous pouviez pas jouer
avec vos jeux playstation 3 c'est pas
possible
donc c'est chouette par contre assez
limité aux jeux playstation 4 on remonte
pas plus que ça dans le temps donc ça
c'est un petit peu dommage donc
malheureusement ma collection de jeux
depuis qui est là depuis plus de vingt
ans chez moi ben voilà il va rester
encore dans le placard parce que je ne
vais pas pouvoir ressortir mes jeux
playstation playstation 2 playstation 3
il ya que les quatre breaks qui
fonctionne et d'ailleurs un truc super
méga cool
si vous êtes abonnés playstation plus
vous allez avoir accès donc là je vois
vous montrer ce que la console n'est pas
en ligne
mais vous allez avoir accès un truc qui
s'appelle playstation plus collection
qui va vous permettre d'accéder
gratuitement c'est au sein de votre
abonnement à une vingtaine de jeux enfin
grosso modo les meilleurs finale de sa
jeune carrière
les meilleurs jeux de la playstation 4
vous y accédez gratuitement dans ce qui
est super si pardon vous n'aviez pas eu
playstation 4 ou 6 bat en fait vous
n'avez pas non plus pu jouer à tous les
super méga jeu
de la console parce que la finance c'est
compliqué donc ça c'est un super c'est
quand même un super cadeau de sony est
donc oui vous pouvez jouer aux jeux
playstation 4 sur votre playstation 5
et il ya quand même des petits ajouts à
lormes alors là on va rentrer dans un
champ extrêmement compliqué mais
dites-vous que un jeu playstation 4 que
vous allez mettre votre playstation 25
il va bénéficier de petites
améliorations donc à minima il va se
charger plus vite parce que maintenant
nous avons abandonné les disques durs
classiques les disques durs mécaniques
pour passer au ssd qui sont des disques
durs pour enfin c'est même pas les
disques durs des disques qui sont on va
dire ultra rapide donc ce qui fait que
par donc quand vous démarrez la
playstation 5
elle démarre en 5 secondes là je vais
pas vous montrer ce qu'on n'est pas en
ligne
mais le playstation store c'est immédiat
pour aller dessus vous avez plus vous
allez l'horrible tant de changements
pour aller sur le playstation store
ça c'est immédiat quand vous allez dans
les menus vous voyez vont à ces ultra
fluide il n'y a pas il y avait toujours
une petite latence sur playstation 4 le
temps que sa charge tous les contenus
qui viennent d'internet etc
enfin pas c'est toujours un petit peu
lent et bah quand vous lancez un jeu bah
c'est super rapide donc là je vais vous
le montre et je vous montrerai après sur
spider man
vous verrez que lens et spider man c'est
juste la folie parce qu'il n'ya pas de
temps de chargement
après ça c'est la règle de base
pardon sur the last of the en fait on
gagne pas vraiment de temps fait ça va
dépendre des jo il ya des jeux qui vont
avoir des patchs donc c'est le cas par
exemple de gossau tsushima il a reçu un
patch la semaine dernière qui permet au
jeu d'être en 4k 60 fps
voilà quand vous y jouez sur playstation
sur playstation 5 alors que sur
playstation 4 il est capé à 30 fps
donc voilà c'est ça c'est au bon vouloir
des développeurs ils peuvent vous
rajoutez laurent et on va vous mettre un
mode spécial playstation 4 pc shon 5
pardon on va libérer le framerate
on va rajouter ben voilà on va passer en
4k mais ça c'est voilà ça va dépendre
des jeux mais a minima ce sera quand
même super jouable est super sympa
justement en parlant de ce ssd on a une
question des lits devos qui nous demande
si on a des informations concernant le
stockage qui reste le gros problème de
ce nom de cette next gen moins de 7 100
giga réellement utilisable et des
stockages externes ssd qui coûte une
fortune
oui donc oui bah là c'est un peu le
problème de cette console c'est que
alors on vous dit que c'est un disque de
800 et quelques gigas mais quand vous
enlevez en fait tout ce qui sert au
système il ne reste que 650 je crois
giga de libre ce qui peut partir assez
du temps quand vous voyez que le dernier
call of duty
on frôle si vous téléchargez tous ont
frôlé les 2 100 giga voilà vous mettez 3
call of duty et c'est terminé
bon ça évidemment le call of duty dont
un petit peu abusé un jeu par exemple
assassin's creed va là il fait 40 giga
donc
mais bon ça va quand même se remplir
vite donc basque après ce que vous
pouvez faire c'est notamment si vous
avez une très bonne connexion à internet
bah c'est que les jeux vous êtes
installé puis voulait supprimer et de
toute manière vous re télécharger vu que
il sait que vous avez la licence soit
parce que vous l'avez acheté sur le psn
soit parce que vous avez le disque si
vous voulez y rejouer bon ben vous ré
installer le jeu sur votre sur votre
console ça globalement sur la quand même
assez vite mais c'est vrai que ça peut
être un peu un peu pénible de supprimer
les jeux bon moi je sais que j'ai fait
je n'ai fait que ça sent la playstation
parce que j'avais pas le modèle le
modèle à 1 tera j'avais le modèle 500
500 giga donc oui j'ai supprimé
énormément de choses ça un rythme à
prendre et ça que si vous voulez
rajouter du stockage supplémentaire
officiel ça coûte beaucoup trop cher
d'accord ça coûte beaucoup trop cher je
crois que c'est 270 euros un truc comme
ça enfin donc c'est supprimez supprimez
les jeux vous quoi faites de la place
sur votre disque dur et d'imprimer le
jeu quand vous avez comme les candidats
aient fini bon bah voilà vous vous
enlevez le jeu de votre votre disque dur
façon ça va garder vos sauvegardes ça va
laisser stockés à part vos sauvegardes
le je vous le disais installé et puis
voilà alors on a beaucoup beaucoup de
questions a essayé de vous répondre à
tous ainsi on prend même un peu de temps
répondre n'hésitez pas à re poser vos
questions et a surtout à rester avec
nous parce que le but du jeu vraiment
c'est de vous répondre au maximum et
alors justement alors pour vous répondre
à tous profitons-en
on va prendre un peu de temps pour vous
répondre avant de vous parler de ce
spider man miles
morales on a notamment alors je vais
remonter un peu dans le flux de
questions qui est venu et on va vous
répondre à tous je vois notamment votre
question canada par exemple tom payne
qui nous demandait tout à l'heure sur
youtube claude thibault avez vous des
jeux que vous attendez alors moi je
dirais cyberpunk je ne pense pas être le
seul à attendre ça répondra d'ailleurs à
votre question ce qu'elle tech fouta qui
nous demandait est ce que les jeux psk
devons continuer à sortir bah oui en
l'occurrence corée avant de sortir un
smartphone par exemple sera disponible
sur les deux plateformes mais en fait ça
y est c'est pire que ça en fait
officiellement cider peu ne sort pas sur
plus de la chaîne cinq ans va-t-il ne
sort que sur playstation 4
mais comme la playsation 5 l'ipv4 en
fait seither peut être apportée ces sacs
mais bon en fait le vrai side of fame pc
jeunes 5 ne sortira pas avant 2021 voilà
en tout cas qui qui vous répond merci de
vos questions merci de vos messages
aussi bon soit ryan bézy filmons figo
bonsoir également à vous thucydide qui
nous regardent sur la page principale du
figaro qui lui demande s'il y aura une
ps 5 pro aubin voilà attendait la
conserve a pas de sortir vous voulez
mieux mais oui oui très certainement
s'il y aura certainement une version
intermédiaire qui sortira pas dans trois
ans quoi au milieu d'eux en milieu de
génération ça c'est quasiment acquis
mais
mais oui oui grein certainement bonsoir
également à vous cabine club entre ch'ti
merci d'être d'être avec nous on vous
salue pour cette soirée de test je vois
donc votre question canal alors avant
cela on a eu une question qui est
revenue plusieurs fois c'est notamment
la question de chine mais qui 96 on a eu
des bugs lors du test de la machine
oui j'en ai eu j'en ai surtout c'était
avant le lancement officiel donc tout
n'était pas encore très très stable
ce qu'on avait une version non
définitive du firmeware delà de la
console mais oui j'ai eu des bugs j'ai
eu
par exemple j'ai eu le spider man qui
genre frise totalement on peut être
parti d'un coup et plus rien faire donc
j'avais pas d'autre choix que de sortir
du jeu arrêté le jeu et puis le relancer
ça ça m'est arrivé après j'ai vu passer
des horror story à base de mon jeu était
installé sur ma sur le disque dur est
soudainement pouf il ne l'était plus ça
dieu merci ça ne m'est pas arrivé
ce que je pense que j'aurai hurler mais
mais j'ai vu que c'était arrivé à des
gens oui bah j'ai vu oued et là bas par
exemple
donc j'étais pas là mais tout ce qu'on a
raconté pendant la préparation de cette
émission la console à reboot et voilà il
ya eu il y avait un problème bouffer la
redémarrer d'un coup donc le j'espère
que ça ne nous arrivera pas on
maintenant qu'on est en direct
mais oui enfin j'ai trouvé que c'était
pas bougé pas eu ces problèmes sur la
xbox série 6 donc peut-être qu'elle
n'est pas encore tout à fait encore 100%
100% fiable mais bon comme vous le savez
il ya des mises à jour qui tombe tout le
temps et ils sont bien conscients que
quand il ya eu ce genre de problème donc
ça va être corrigé très vite façon le
temps que vous ayez vous trouviez une
playstation 5 j'ai envie de dire je
pense que ces problèmes de fiabilité
seront réglés à temps et que ça va être
compliqué d'en avoir une d'ici la fin
d'année
bonsoir alain du 57 qui nous regardaient
sur la page principale du figaro qui ne
demandent où est la xbox et risbourg l'a
testé il ya quelques jours vous pouvez
retrouver ce test en replay sur le
figaro mais également sur tweets chez
sur youtube n'hésitez pas à le retrouver
si vous souhaitez un petit peu avoir les
capacités les paramètres de la
concurrente directe de ce nouveau-né de
sony merci de votre question kenan vous
demandez s'il est vrai que nous n'aurons
pas de réduction prix sur les jeux de la
ps -cinq 'digital edition donc la
version à 399 euros dans le ps store
banon alors justement il n'y avait pas
prévu que les jeux
soit moins cher si on n'aurait pas les
moins chers parce que vous avez acheté
la console la moins chère ça marche pas
comme ça
non par contre vous allez être dépendant
de la politique de prix du playstation
store
donc ça veut dire que ben si vous voulez
avoir des jeux soldé il faudra attendre
qu'ils aient des soldes sur le
playstation store et les jeux les jeux
neufs les jo qui viennent tout juste de
sortir on sait qu'ils sont plus chers
sur le playstation store 20 plus cher en
fait ils sont au prix normal au prix
auquel il devrait être commercialisé
mais on sait que la grande distribution
notamment fait souvent des promotions et
un vent léger au moins cher qu'elle ne
le devrait
parce que c'est un produit d'appel 1
pour eux donc ils s'en fichent de pas
faire leurs marges sur un jeu
playstation 4 pts 5
mais bref si vous êtes plutôt proche de
vos souhaits que vous voulez pas mais 70
euros voire 80 euros dans vos jeux je
vous conseille fortement de plutôt opté
pour la version à 500 euros
voilà qui vous répond merci de votre
question question n'en ai pas posé pas
mal ça fait plaisir
kenan merci de votre question également
ex or sur tweets cheminots demande si le
temps d'installation des jeux est
toujours aussi longue sur la ps4
moi j'ai trouvé ça assez rapide non non
c'est assez rapide et surtout alors un
truc qui est chouette c'est que si vous
avez un jeu playstation 4 par exemple ça
va pas vous charger sur le playstation
store le jeu vous allez vraiment
installée à partir du disque donc c'est
très rapide pour installer un jeu en
version disque par contre je n'allais
pas et chez théo des milliards de mise à
jour ou alors des trucs très très
piégeux de type vous avez la version
disque mais en fait il n'ya que très
très peu de données sur le disque et la
console va quand même télécharger le jeu
sur le playstation store
ça c'est un petit peu pénible bon ça
c'est ce que j'ai vu passer parce que
moi j'ai je n'ai eu que des jeux n'est
pas une version disque un dd jeu j'étais
jeune et que les versions numériques
mais bon j'ai pas trouvé ça enfin
trousseau c'était pas enfin la lenteur
est élu dû à la lenteur de ma connexion
internet 1 c'est papa s'était pas ce
n'était pas dû à pas dû à la console en
elle-même
merci à tous pour toutes vos questions
bonsoir
à vous de gm tests sur youtube ti bob 57
également bilal heures à kiev alors on a
beaucoup de commentaires de questions
chloé sur un plutôt des commentaires sur
la rupture de stock à la menace les la
ps 5 mais également la xbox series qui
est bien est particulièrement difficile
on a chine mais qui nous dit et c'est le
combat pour la voir avant noël il faut
prendre des touche f5 de rechange
tellement facile on a acheté nos dit
elle sera sûrement disponible après noël
y en aura partout on verra cela je
n'hésitais pas à nous le dire dans les
commentaires dans quelques mois
voilà on a donc beaucoup de questions
relatives à la disponibilité du de la
console alors furent des ricoh qui nous
demandent si le problème que vous aviez
cité un peu plus tôt du jeu qui
disparaît d'un coup du disque dur c'est
sur le ssd ou sur un disque externe
était sur l'asm faisait d'accord voilà
qui vous répond tiens on a une question
qui revenait pas mal avant qu'on aborde
le thème précis de ce spider man qu'on
voit se dérouler sous nos yeux sur bien
par exemple la compatibilité du d'un jeu
comme parions que call of duty qui vient
de sortir
on a par exemple pour des ricoh qui nous
dit il faut faire attention avec call of
duty qui ont installé la version psp
alors que la version ps1 qui étaient
disponibles oui en fait fausse a
malheureusement je pense ça va durer
encore un petit moment faut faire
attention à la version que vous
téléchargez quand vous achetez
directement en ligne
et il ya une manière assez simple je me
souviens plus de l'amanite et c'est
exact mais en gros quand vous appuyez
quand votre jeu à télécharger vous
appuyez sur la touche option et dessus
ça va être marqué les différentes
versions du jeu et ça va être
il va être parqués quelque chose du
genre pop gré des vers la version
playstation s'incline et donc ça va vous
permettre déjà de voir si vous avez bien
la bonne version est si jamais par
erreur vous avez téléchargé la version
playstation 4
il va vous mettre automatiquement la
version pc chanson on a
nick sort qui qui nous dit si on a une
connexion internet au rabais ça ne sert
pas à grand chose de prendre l'appel 5
j'ai envie de dire banide à xbox
téléchargement si on n'a pas la fibre
c'est un peu compliqué barfoed a
malheureusement plus on avance dans le
temps j'ai à dire hormis la switch
maintenant toutes les consoles sont
connectés toutes les consoles demande
des chargements conséquent même si vous
optez pour les versions 10 qu'il y aura
quand même des fichiers mise à jour à
installer donc oui plus ça vient si vous
n'avez pas une grosse connexion c'est un
petit peu galère mais par contre un truc
qui est quand même assez chouette c'est
que désormais notamment avec les
applications de sausseau de la xbox de
playstation vous pouvez commander à
distance votre console pour dire voilà
télécharge ce jeu pendant chez au
travail dans le télécharge ce jeu
pendant que je suis au lycée pendant que
je suis en cours comme ça si vous avez
une petite connexion vous lancez votre
téléchargement le matin et quand vous
rentrez le soir a priori ce sera ce sera
bon ce sera quasiment finissent ainsi
vous avez vraiment une connexion jeux
jeux que je connais votre douleur parce
que môssieur sais pas je suis toujours
en adsl mais je pense que ça ira en fait
cette génération va me convaincre de
passer à la fibre jusqu'à présent je
résistais real alors on a une question
de kenan sur twitch qui nous demandent
combien de ports usb se trouve à l'avant
de la console est ce qu'il y en à
l'arrière alors il ya il ya deux ports
il ya un port usb
il y en a deux qui envoyait deux ports
usb à l'avant d'accord agnès b c est un
usb classique et à l'arrière
attendez il y en a deux voilà qui qui
vous répond qu' henan très précisément
alors passons à ce spider man miles
morales qui est en train de se jouer
sous nos yeux
jusque là on avait un commentaire de
hache sur youtube qui nous disait ce
spider man est plutôt un gros dlc du
premier spider man qui était sortie sur
ps4 qui avait été un succès retentissant
l'un des plus grands succès de
l'histoire du jeu vidéo
de loin le jeu de super-héros qui s'est
le plus vendu de l'histoire
qu'est ce que sony qui s'est extrêmement
bien vendu
je regarde ce qui se sont mieux vendus
sur cette génération donc alors j'ai pas
gelé je ne vais pas finir pas encore
parce que comme vous savez il ya
tellement de jeux qui sont sortis que
c'est un peu compliqué mais moi je le
trouve très plaisant à jouer très sympa
apprendre à prendre en main c'est pour
moi c'est le jeu le plus accessible de
ce lancement de la playstation 5 parce
que c'est grand spectacle c'est pas très
dur
enfin après vous rêvez la difficulté
comme vous voulez moi pour ce soir que
je prenne mon pied au centre on prendre
la tête j'ai mis en mode facile mais
vous pouvez mettre en super facile si
vous voulez vous pouvez mettre aussi en
super difficile si c'est votre cliff et
bas surtout le jeu est super super joli
après ça reste un open world avec tous
les côtés que j'aime pas c'est à dire
vous avez plein d'objets à trouver
collecter et quand vous avez enfin finir
un truc audi et et là maintenant et il y
en a dix mignard sur la map
il va falloir les trouver aussi ça sera
pénible je préfère me concentrer sur
l'émission donc vous avez barre comme
structure de open world classic vous
avez missions principales missions
secondaires activités donc là en fait
vous avez une sorte d'application sur
votre téléphone par le téléphone du jeu
qui permet aux gens de signaler
quand ils ont besoin de spiderman et
même quand vous vous baladez dans la
ville ben il y aura tout le temps tout
le temps des gens qui vont diront genre
lundi donc là il ya un crime un là il se
passe il a il se passe ça donc en fait
limite automne jamais tranquille mais
après bon vous choisissez si vous voulez
si vous pouvez y aller ou pas c'est
votre c'est votre choix c'est votre
choix donc
donc oui c'est un jeu où vous êtes sans
cesse sollicités donc on aime ou on
n'aime pas moi j'avoue j'aime bien me
balader penarol a oui pardon est ce que
j'ai vu je suis concentré sur ce que je
raconte ça va forcément me concentrer
sur le jeu machine mais qui ne dit c'est
sûr que par rapport à dimane sauce et la
balade de santé
ah bah oui clairement c'est on n'est pas
du tout sont l'âme niveau difficulté on
sait c'est pas c'est pas la même chose
un bon l'âge si tout à l'heure aux
bourgeois demon soul ce je vous avoue
que de là je ne parlerai pas en jeu
j'essaierai de ne pas trop me milliers
devant vous alors on veut répondre à
votre question james test une question
qu'on a déjà abordé mais on va on va
revenir là dessus pour vous est ce que
la nouvelle manette est vraiment si
novatrice apporte une nouvelle sensation
de jeu bas à ce que nous disait chloé
oui tout à fait maintenant il va falloir
voir si des jeux exploitent lors des
sorties des mois et des années à venir
on sera très curieux mais en tout cas
dans les capacités qu'elle qu'elle
propose tout à fait avec donc un retour
de force et aussi plein de nouvelles
capacités qu'on n'avait pas dans la
version de la ps4
voilà pour pour vous répondre
james test merci de votre question et on
a une très bonne question de kenan qui
nous demande
ce qui nous pose une question sur un
l'une des capacités de cette ps5
si on active le raytracing sur ce point
par exemple y aura-t-il une baisse de
fps alors si le raytracing pour nos
internautes
alors je vous montrerai le ray tracing
quand j'aurai fini cette séquence
d'action mais pour le
dire simplement le ray tracing c'est une
nouvelle technologie qui va agir sur la
lumière et ce qui va ça se voit surtout
sur les reflets donc le ray tracing donc
là que vous montrerez beaucoup de tout à
l'heure c'est par exemple là vous voyez
je passe devant un plein d' affiches
plein de vie plein de vitres là je ne
suis pas en mode pas pardon je sauve un
bébé
je ne suis pas en mode rétrécit je suis
en mode 60 fps d'accord parce que moi je
préfère le jeu en 60 fps mais ça va
faire que quand vous regardez les
vitrines vous allez voir spider man se
refléter vous allez voir les lumières
environnantes se refléter sur les vitres
sur les affiches publicitaires dans la
neige sur la neige dans l'eau dans les
flaques d'eau enfin bref c'est c'est une
nouvelle technologie après moi vous
avoue en action vous faites pas
attention à ça et donc moi j'avoue je
préfère jouer en 60fps parce qu'on sent
vraiment la différence
enfin moi qui viens je touche une 100%
console aux je ne joue pas du tout sur
pc je ne comprenais pas quand les
pécéistes s'extasier sur le 60 fps
ouais et maintenant que j'ai goûté ben
je comprends j'ai vu les lumières
donc voilà je n y étais 6 je vous ai
compris
et la voilà je jouais en 60 fps est
passée juste un bonheur sur un jeu aussi
rapide un jeu d'action c'est vraiment
super mais je vous montrerai tout à
l'heure voilà dès que j'aurai fini cette
séquence de poursuite je vous montrerai
la différence entre les deux modes et
vous allez voir aller assez criantes bon
on va on va regarder ça avec attention
voilà qui qui vous répond en tout cas qu
anna merci de votre question indique non
pour rebondir sur votre question h sur
youtube ce que vous avez prévu de la
prendre cette ps5
ce que voilà vous avez prévu de
l'acheter tout de suite maintenant est
ce que vous êtes sur votre clavier à
attendre que de nouvelles offres
disponibles pour avoir la vôtre est ce
qu'un verre vous avez préféré vous
procurer sa concurrente en la xbox
series n'hésitez pas à nous dire ce sera
avec plaisir
alors on va essayer de vous de vous
répondre merci four des ricoh en tout
cas de votre question vous nous dites le
raytracing et très coûteux en calcul en
calcul manque ça n'était ce n'étaient
pas utilisables en temps réel mais en
effet ces récents pour le jeu vidéo
on a une question de
enzo le gamer avant de prendre votre
question je vais revenir sur votre
commentaire chine mais qui nous dit
j'avoue que je lai précommander pour
faire le bêta testeurs alors que les
autres playstation j'ai toujours attendu
au moins un an
mais je les prises vraiment pour demon
soul va écouter merci de votre
commentaire on espère que vous y
trouverez votre plaisir pour vous kenan
et bien vous attendez vous vous attendez
vous économisez mais écoutez voilà on
espère que que vous l'aurez on a une
question de enzo le gamer qui demande
sur youtube si la ps 5 c'est un tout
seul alors j'imagine que sans parler de
de bugs en fait là on est plutôt sur
simplement une programmation on peut lui
demander en termes d'économie d'énergie
de s'éteindre si a pas de oui oui bah ça
vous avez vous et vous avez les
les options habituelles vous pouvez dire
bon après j'ai pas dix minutes 15
minutes 20 minutes une heure
d'inactivité la console c'est un oedème
ouvre les manettes
enfin oui vous avez toujours ses options
là qui existe voilà donc pour vous
répondre
bonsoir guillaume kevin chose sur
youtube merci de nous rejoindre
voilà en tout cas merci d'être avec nous
si nombreux ce soir on prend
vous voyez vos commentaires ce sera avec
plaisir si vous avez aussi des questions
alors j'avais cette question décidément
qui revient vraiment à ce soir on a
vraiment de questions qui reviennent la
première c'est sur la manette delà de la
ps 5 1 qui semble beaucoup vous
intéresser à juste titre puisque l offre
beaucoup de choses c'est par exemple
votre cas sode 93 pouvez vous donner des
informations sur la dualshock 4 sur ps1
alors c'est pas la 2e d'accord sur
l'utilisation de la précédente manette
sur cette console est ce que c'est
possible est ce qu'il ya une
rétrocompatibilité de je vous avoue que
je n'ai pas essayé mais j'imagine
j'imagine que oui j'imagine que oui mais
là je le préfère ne pas donner une
réponse définitive
voilà est-ce que pour répondre à la
chine mais vous avez eu des crampes en
essayant cette manette et son retour
haptique non pas du tout pas du tout
alors j'ai vu des gens qui s'en sont
plaints moi non franchement sa part
après bon ça dépend des tailles dément
je pense en mai
moi ça va je pensais avoir une taille
demeure standard donc non mais ça va pas
poser de souci j'ai pas j'ai pas eu donc
rendu pas une malfaçon il gâte tellement
peu de jeux qui utilisent vraiment les
mac les gages adaptatif que c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment un souci
ouais dans le seul alors pour être
honnête le sait dans astro playroom il
ya un niveau où il faut vraiment
utiliser à fond les gages adaptatif tout
en bougeant tout en bougeant à la
manette en
en giroptic et je vous avoue là ça m'a
fait un peu mal au poignet samassa m'a
fait mal parce qu'il faut vraiment bougé
à mort et j'ai pas trouvé ça très très
agréable comme sensation
sa dot mais j'ose od jamais mais ouais
j'ai j'ai pas trop aimé j'ai pas trop
aimé à lorenzo gamer vous nomme aussi
les jeux de la ps4 rond sur ps -cinq oui
tout à fait il ya une rétrocompatibilité
que vous les ayez en matériel donc en cd
ou en des matériels directement sur le
ps store
voilà qui vous répond on a alors je vous
disais tout à l'heure que deux questions
reviennent la première c'est sur les
manettes de la ps5
la seconde c'est sur les stocks de la ps
-cinq que vous êtes nombreux à prendre
en compte est bien en effet vous nous
demandez reddan tourabi quand est ce que
l'on voit sur va s'approprier cette ds5
bas il va falloir être patient et être
suspendus aux réseaux sociaux notamment
avec des comptes comme celui de amstar
joueur qui va vous donne des nouvelles
des coeurs des stocks se sont fait chez
les différents revendeurs voilà pour
vous répondre
au passage on salue v entertainment tv
que j'ai plaisir à retrouver ça fait
longtemps qu'on ne vous a pas vu sur
twitter merci d'être avec nous vous nous
demandez vous nous dites vous tester des
jeux maintenant je suis surpris il va
écouter on fait du jeu vidéo depuis très
longtemps depuis 2016 on teste beaucoup
beaucoup de jeu on a là on a la chance
de pouvoir tester cette nouvelle
génération de consoles mais on peut
tester beaucoup de joueurs chloé on a pu
tester les dernières grosses sorties
moi je vous donne rendez-vous d'ailleurs
pour la sortie de cyberpunk on va vous
proposer un test on verra si ça vaut le
coup j'espère que oui merci en tout cas
vers times and tv d'être avec nous ça
fait plaisir de vous retrouver
on a une question
de kenan sur l'enregistrement vidéo de
l'écran e
comment ça fonctionne et ce qu'on pourra
choisir la qualité de l'enregistrement
et la fréquence d'image oui oui oui ça
avait des options très très précises en
fait sur la qualité des images donc soit
que vous capturez donc juste les photos
les captures d'écran mais aussi des
vidéos que vous diffusez s'est enfui en
fonction de votre que votre connexion
internet lorsque vous streamés sur
youtube ou sur tweets vous avez vous
avez plein de possibilités voilà vous
pouvez stream et en cas de cas si jamais
vous pouvez comme vous pouvez stream est
en 720p
si jamais vous n'avez pas non plus une
connexion de folie donc non non tout est
paramétrable franchement les paramètres
de la console sont très complet vous
avez de quoi vous amuser
est-ce que vous avez des on parlait tout
à l'heure des stocks mais pour répondre
à bilal ragheb et reddan tourabi si la
ps -cinq on a des nouvelles sur les
stocks
al'approche de noël alors non en gros là
ce qu'on sait c'est que il y aura du
réassort d'ici noël
mais ce sera il y en aura pas beaucoup y
en a pas beaucoup et ça va être
compliqué pour se procurer une
playstation 5 de ce que m'a dit sony
janvier février mars peut-être au-delà
en fait tout va dépendre de la des
capacités de production donc ils font
leur maximum pour augmenter les cadences
au niveau des usines mais voilà ils
savent que là les stocks vont être bien
moindre par rapport à la demande
donc préparez vous à ce que ce soit un
petit peu un petit peu compliqué voilà
en tout cas chine mais qui ne dit la
fnac a annoncé des stocks disponibles le
15 décembre prépare ta touche f5 bah oui
carrément
voilà pour ça on a une question
intéressante qu'on n'a pas encore abordé
alors avant de l'aborder c'est votre
question et
attendez que je vous retrouve sur la
télévision la meilleure télévision qu'on
pourrait avoir
on va déjà abordé alors attendez parce
que là ça y est on a une avalanche de
questions
au passage on salue kenan qui nous
quitte on vous remercie d'avoir passé un
petit bout de soirée avec nous pour
tester cette nouvelle ps5
le temps que tu trouves ouais je vais
vous montrer la différence entre les
modes
ben voilà c'est dit et c'est le seul je
cherchais on avait voilà cette question
de for the games sur twitter qui nous
demandent s'il ya une différence
perceptible entre louis 60 fps et le 120
fps on parlait de stargate racing est là
juste là pour quoi vous montrer tout ça
alors le 120 fps on n'y est pas encore
le 120 fps c'est la promesse à l'avenir
mais il n'y a aucun jeu qui sont 120 f
-s en ce moment ça se dit on aura
peut-être quelques-uns dans cinq ans
mais pour le moment on en est c'est soit
30 fps soit 60 fps donc là ça se voit
très très bien sur spider man pour ça je
vais vous montrer les différences entre
les deux modes via je suis en mode ray
tracing à 30fps d'accord donc là ce que
vous voyez si vous regardez le sol si
vous voyez que c'est humide on voit un
peu la neige on voit que ça ça glisse un
peu et vous voyez des reflets donc là
par exemple vous voyez les messieurs qui
sont en train de traverser vous voyez
leur reflet dans le sol sais pas si vous
voyez bien mais c'est leurs reflets en
temps réel je vais essayer de trouver un
endroit où il ya des vitres pour que
vous puissiez mieux voir mais grosso
modo l'idée du ray tracing c'est que ben
voilà alors par exemple la flaque d'eau
que vous voyez au milieu de la rue vous
voyez qu'elle reflète fidèlement
l'immeuble qui est juste à côté ça c'est
laisser la magie du ray tracing ce qui
est impossible dans l'autre mode ne sera
pas le faire en fautif il faudra des
reflets mais un petit peu grossier on va
dire et par exemple alors j'essaie de me
rapprocher de vitres up
voila voila voyez quand je marche sur
les sur les vitres on voit mon ombre et
on voit la rue on voit la rue juste
derrière moi donc j'essaie de vous
montrer ça au mieux mais voilà on voit
les immeubles on voit les voitures qui
passent enfin c'est vraiment un reflet
fidèle du jeu de tout ce qui se passe
derrière
donc ça c'est ce qu'apporte le ray
tracing tout ça apporte des des reflets
qui sont hyper réaliste et mais par
contre le prix à payer c'est que vous
êtes en trente espèces
donc là ça voulait dire si vous êtes un
joueur console si vous êtes un joueur
console voilà vous à dire oui bon 30fps
j'ai l'habitude ça me choque pas c'est
paraissent pas plus grave c'est un
constat donc j'ai ouï abandonné
l'édition et voilà je vais remonter là
haut
voilà ouf maintenant on va passer en
mode 60 fps donc ça se fait dans
réglages graphisme et on passe en
performance et là aussi le saint-james
ça me permet de vous montrer la rapidité
des temps de chargement donc il va me
dire il faut alors hop
pourquoi il veut pas qu'est ce qui se
passe du direct ah bah oui c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon quoi là appliqués et
redémarrer donc là il va redémarrer je
vois là j'ai à peine 10 souffre notre
jeu a redémarré et là je suis en 60 fps
alors je sais pas si ça se voit sur le
sur le flux sur le stream
et bien croyez moi sur parole serait
c'est un autre jeu
le jeu est beaucoup plus fin le jeu est
beaucoup plus rapide et je trouve
beaucoup plus agréable à l'oeil
par contre vous allez perdre tous les
faits du ray tracing tous les reflets
tous les reflets donc pas donc je vais m
voilà sur un immeuble
ouais vous voyez qu'il ya déjà des
reflets mais ils sont quand même un
petit peu plus grossier donc je ne sais
pas à proprement parler leur vrai reflet
de ce qui se passe dans le jeu c'est
plutôt une sorte de voile à alger entre
guillemets de ce qui est censé voilà
vous voyez vous voyez que derrière moi
il ya on voit pas les véhicules qui qui
bouge
voilà le voyez il ya de la circulation
et balla sur leur faim on va pas voir on
va pas voir les voitures qui bouge alors
qu'il ya des voitures il ya des voitures
dans la rue il ya des gens qui marchent
et c'est ça on va pas le voir dans le
mode qui n'est pas rétréci mais qui à 60
fps est pareil sur les reflets les
reflets dans les flaques les reflets
dans la neige
bon on va avoir grossièrement ont
grossièrement vous mettez de beaucoup de
guillemets autour
le soleil qui se reflète mais on voit un
petit peu mon nombre mais voilà mais
sans plus mais il ya beaucoup moins
d'effets que sur le mode le mode
fidélité est donc là pour que vous le
voyez encore plus on va repasser en mode
fidélité
hop le je redémarre
voyez la rapidité pour moi déjà moi je
le sens à fondeyre passer à 30 fps
eh ben il va y avoir beaucoup plus de
voix là les voiles et des gens dont on
perçoit de beaucoup plus les reflets les
reflets au sol les reflets dans les
vitres je suis le maître sur un sur un
immeuble que vous les voyez là c'est
dommage qu'on soit pas de nuit parce que
ça ça se voit mieux quand on est quand
on est de nuit mais la voix y voilà vous
voyez que le reflet qui est derrière moi
ça n'a rien à avoir avec le reflet qu'on
avait tout à l'heure qui était un petit
peu un petit peu grossier là c'est
vraiment passé un miroir de ce qui se
passe derrière
donc voilà les grosses différences entre
le mode racing et le mode 60 fps donc là
malheureusement 60 fps je peux pas vous
montrer le bonheur que ces deux joué en
60 fps
parce que le flux le feu ne permet pas
qu'on vous envoie malheureuse pour
malheureusement dépenses sur tbs donc on
ne pourrait pas le voir mais après voilà
vous pouvez zapper d'un mode à l'autre
donc c'est à vous de jauger de juger
lequel est de vous préférez voilà pour
va pour vous répondre et surtout pour
vous faire une démo en direct un verre
cyclos et alors on avait entertainment
et mais qui ne dit que vous avez pris le
sac chris thompson chatons intéressant
pour troller en live c'est un vrai qu on
n'a pas beaucoup de nouveaux arrivants
qu'on salue sur la page principale du
figaro bonsoir
benjamin lui besoin ce qui tient qui
vous pouvez retrouvez d'ailleurs sur
notamment la chaîne youtube du figaro
qui vous offre des séances d'hypnose via
vidéo n'hésitez pas à le retrouver
également sur sa sur sa chaîne youtube
personnel on vous savez en tout cas vous
le demande et si le son 360 c'est bien
alors oui c'est un des gros atouts de la
console en fait c'est le son le son 3d
pour le moment vous pourrez en profiter
qu avec un casque audio
pour le mans s'est pas encore adapté au
home cinéma si jamais vous avez ça par
contre si vous avez un trade un bon
casse que voilà que vous écoutez pour
vous utilisez pour écouter de la musique
et que c'est un c'est un casque plutôt
sympa vous allez profiter du fait voilà
du son spatialisé donc oui c'est c'est
c'est un petit plus mais bon voilà il
faut jouer au casque pour en profiter
merci de votre question alors justement
on avait et on a eu beaucoup de
réactions notamment de de votre part
mike jokes on a eu également d'autres
personnes qui nous en ont parlé for the
games c'est la question du choix de la
télévision fois il faut jouer à la paix
est 5 pour vraiment exploiter les
capacités de cette console va écouter
tout va dépendre de votre budget lorsque
je tiens un désir c'est que si vous avez
une télé full hd vous allez quand même
profiter de la playstation simple parce
que c'est mon cas je n'ai pas télévision
kdka et je vois quand même je vois quand
même la différence enfin je vois que je
suis plus sur playstation 4
je vois que c'est quand même vachement
plus beau je vois surtout je profite du
mode 60 fps
alors certes j'ai pas le hdr sur ma sur
ma télé
mais bon il ya déjà un saut un sort
graphique qui se sont si vous avez déjà
une télé hd air bals abbas et c'est
chouette pour vous le top du top c'est
évidemment d'avoir une télévision quatre
cas de bonne qualité le top du top si
vous êtes vraiment si vous voulez
vraiment investir pour l'avenir c'est
vous prenez une télévision kdka
compatible 120 fps mais par contre vous
allez vous ruminez et du cou
le 120 fps à l'intention de rentrer dans
des considérations techniques
il faut qu'ils aient une entrée hdmi 2.5
pour que ça fonctionne et les consoles
sont livrés avec le câble hdmi qui
idoine donc surtout conserver le parce
que si ça se trouve aujourd'hui vous
n'aurez vous n'avez pas de télévision
compatible 120 fps mais vous serez
contente d'avoir le bon câble dans
quelques années si jamais vous fait
l'investissement et donc voilà oui le
top du top c'est d'avoir une télé 4 4 4
ko l'aide hdr et tous les poètes voilà à
la mode mais je vous avoue plongé un peu
dans la question parce que je me dis il
était temps que j'ai investi dans une
nouvelle télé c'est un peu la jungle
pour pour s'y retrouver
c'est un petit peu compliqué surtout si
on veut pas mettre trois mille euros
dans une télévision
au moins si on veut pas mettre 1500
euros c'est un petit peu c'est un petit
peu dur en tant que n'hésitez pas à vous
renseigner à bien écumé internet les
forums les avis consommateurs parce que
bon c'est pas non plus un navire à quai
comme c'est beau quand même c'est pas
l'investissement
qui est léger c'est quand même si vous
voulez vraiment une très très bonne
télévision va falloir compter au moins
1000 euros vraiment si vous voulez le
top donc et ça c'est un grand minimum
donc donc voilà mais je le répète si
vous avez une télévision 1080p full hd
etc
vous avez quand même bien profité c'est
quand même bien profiter de la console
bonsoir à vous qui nous rejoignent et
sur la page principale du figaro sur
youtube et sur twitch on est avec vous
avec grand plaisir pour tester cette
nouvelle ps 5 le dernier né de la marque
sony
n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos questions
nous
donnez aussi vos commentaires on a un
commentaire qui revient très souvent ça
fait des années que je fais du stream et
du live est ce que c'est le vrai figaro
nous demandons bel et bien oui c'est
bien nous en fait du stream depuis très
longtemps que ce soit sur twitch sur
facebook aussi sur la page principale du
figaro n'hésitez pas à nous retrouver
régulièrement on vous offre beaucoup
d'actualité que ce soit vidéoludique
mais également général voilà bonsoir
également à vous zisis sur youtube merci
petit pain d'épicés si vous auriez
tester l'application my canal l'appli
contre est-elle comme deuxième décodeur
c'est un peu précis comme aux questions
sur chloé et surtout mal canal je crois
qu'elle est disponible que sur la xbox
est né je ne crois pas qu'elle soit
disponible sur la playstation 5
bon ben voilà qui vous répond merci en
tout cas d'être
être avec nous merci également pour vos
messages force de game et wenger
telemann tv sur twitch c'est toujours un
plaisir en tout cas même si c'est un
plaisir de faire du stream actu mais
c'est un plaisir aussi de rester dans
l'actu vidéoludique puisqu'on retrouve
plein de personnes qu'on a plaisir à
retrouver
voilà donc en tout cas pour ce spider
man est ce que pour moi que le vous
pourriez testé dimanche sous la halle à
quelques internautes je sais que vous le
redouté avec 200 tonnes qui avaient
envie en tout cas de le voir tourner ok
on y vend à dieu
votre réputation j'en profite pour vous
montrer un peu l'interface
donc voilà ça c'est quand vous appuyez
sur le bouton ps qui est jeune et en la
réalisation peut nous montrer voilà qui
est entre les deux sticks c'est le
bouton à tout faire et c'est le bouton
qui va vous offrir ces raccourcis
notamment les captures d'écran seul vous
allez trouver mais vous avez tout ce
qu'ils appellent ses lecteurs dont s'est
emparé de lancer très vite des jeux dont
demon's souls mais on y va après et
c'est là vous avez vos notifications
comment créer des partis pour jouer en
ligne mais de la musique si vous êtes
abonné à spotify dont c'est vous pouvez
écouter votre musique tout en jouant
c'est plutôt cool réglages de son
réglage de micro accessoires votre
compte psn
enfin c'est vraiment la touche la touche
à tout faire et donc diamond solde des
masses est parti j'ai un petit peu peur
je sens le feu assure toi en régie on
rigole on va voir ce que ça donne c'est
voilà c'est le digne même pas héritier
en fait ce jeudi ne pas pas d'aidé dark
souls
on va voir ce que ça donne ah là là j'ai
un peu par je me suis entraîné un g j'ai
demandé à un coach de m'aider mais voilà
je vais faire en sorte de ne pas être
ridicule non et surtout je vais prendre
une classe de personnage qui est un
petit peu cités pour pour que ce soit un
peu plus simple
voilà bah n'hésitez pas à nous donner
vos impressions du jeu de chloé on va
voir cela tout de suite comment ça se
passe moi j'avoue que j'ai essayé le 1
et enfin d'arc sous 1 et j'ai abandonné
tout de suite je me suis mis plus tôt à
d'autres jeux pour essayer de survivre
dans le monde que je vais vidéoludique
c'est parti je me remets des pertes
allez c'est parti
hb qui nous dit enfin un jeu intéressant
un vrai jeu alors avant qu'on croise le
hamas a déjà croisé allez on ne parle
plus on voulait s'imprégner de cette
performance
tata à lui il était gentil on a une
question que le riz de thomas legrand
sur youtube qu'on salue qui demandent si
un téléviseur oled et bien pour le jeu
vidéo plutôt sony ou lg
ouais je vais pas rentrer dans ces
considérations mais en tout cas sachez
que sony a rajouté maintenant des petits
logos pour dire
perfect for playstation 5 ou widi for
playstation 5 dont c'est pour vous dire
c'est les téléviseurs qui sont bien
adaptés à la au jeu vidéo et notamment
vos réglages la playsation 5 vous êtes à
peu près sûr de ne pas vous tromper
alors tout cas chine mais celui votre
performance sakho a bah ça commence bien
ouais bah je demande si ça spoile non
c'est un space et le alors c'est le tout
début les joueurs là c'est vraiment
c'est le tout tout tout début du jeu
dont je prends pas de risque car je fais
tout juste le début après on s'arrête
non j'ai une réaction c'est que alors ce
jeu est certes beau mais pourquoi de me
l'avoir sorti que sur ps1 qu'est ce que
c'était pour pour jouer un peu sur live
de la sortie et booster un peu les
sorties de ps1 qu est-ce qu à l inverse
c'est un jeu qui exploite des capacités
que la ps4 ne pourrait pas bon au nom il
pourrait tout à fait sortir sur ps4 mais
je pense qu'il avait juste besoin d'une
exclusivité d'une exclusivité purement
paie 5 est vrai que ben quand vous
regardez le je vais quand même
extrêmement jolimont l' ange
ah ah bon là je triche un peu un
j'utilise la magie parce que là la magie
ça permet au moins de voix de taper au
loin et moi je ne mourrai pas de manière
ridicule pendant cependant ce live elie
de vos seins qui vous
qui me soutient l'asie clos et on est
tous avaient l'air c'est quand même
dingue quinquin je suscite autant de 2,2
comment dire de peur et de et de
compétences nécessaires je repasse à
l'épée hop voilà n'hésitez pas en tout
cas si vous avez des confirmations des
commentaires que ce soit sur les sur les
compétences de chloé m'est égal à sur
les compères à 605 on les prend avec
grand plaisir alors on a par exemple on
a par exemple chine mais qui nous dit à
mon dieu le jeu est beau c'est vrai
quand on a de très beaux écrans là c'est
très joli
on avait entertainment et b qui nous dit
qui rebondit sur ce qu'on disait qu'il
m'a dit qu'avec le coc vide
ben sonia va avoir besoin de doper un
peu les les ventes de consoles vu les
chutes du pouvoir d'achat ben oui c'est
vrai que c'est une période un peu un peu
complexe tu en as une question de for
the games qui 96 demon soul ce n'est que
du combat bah oui oui c'est que c'est du
combat mais c'est pas du combat on
bourrine oms et du combat compliqué ça
mais c'est pas le genre de jeu où il
faut collectionner 55 comme un superman
50 collectibles comme on dit en anglais
a annoncé un jeu c'est un jeu où il faut
voir vous avez différentes zones qui
sont l'avenir atik vous n'avez pas de
carte va faire débloquer des raccourcis
et surtout il va falloir survivre ce
qu'il n'est pas évident donc là je en
fait là je suis en mode zéro risque pour
pour pas que ce soit ridicule mais en
fait vous pouvez mourir très rapidement
il ya très très peu de points de
sauvegarde dont vous êtes obligé de
recommencer recommencer recommencer
jusqu'à ce que vous appreniez
voilà le comportement des ennemis et
qu'elles soient un peu leur patterns et
que vous vous trouviez des raccourcis
que voulait débloquer donc donc ouais
c'est ce n'est pas un jeu évident et
c'est pas le jeu que je recommanderais à
des gens qui n'ont pas
enfin qui n'ont pas beaucoup de patience
bref c'est le jeu parfait à offrir aux
tout-petits aujourd'hui on donne déjà de
fait on a une question tiens qui nous
avait déjà posé que j'ai raté de fournir
10 coups sûrs twitch qui nous demandent
la longueur des câbles manette hdmi ils
sont plus lents que sur ps4
donc ça c'est chouette mais ils sont pas
non plus à vue n'est faux 1 m 1 m 20 je
dirais mais ils sont plus longs que ceux
de la ps4
voilà qui vous répond justement en fait
ça nous ramène à une partie qu'on n'a
pas abordé et qui est pourtant la plus
flagrante celle de l'ergonomie
on est face à un pavé alors déjà on l'a
dit pour la xbox series mais alors là
c'est plus qu'un pavé c'est plus qu'un
frigo 4,5 kg pour une console qui est
particulièrement imposante vous le voyez
vous pas raison de clauses sur cet écran
c'est assez impressionnant alors pour
rigoler on avait vu que xbox series
avait sorti un frigo sous l'effigié de
la xbox series rapport à sa taille
là clairement on efface façon un monstre
ah ouais excusez moi mais bien j'ai un
monsieur méchant qui arrive
ah oui on mais c'est une console qui est
énorme
et surtout elle va pas rentrer dans tous
les noter et enfin dans le mien alors
elle réussit à rentrer mais il a fallu
faire beaucoup de place au tour parce
que c'est une console qui avait un
besoin aussi de respirer
elle a besoin d'avoir alors sony
conseille dix centimètres de chaque côté
de la console pour qu'elles puissent
voilà qu'elle allait vraiment petit nom
n'approche pas trop s'il te plaît voilà
non là je pense 0 risquer ta magie donc
oui c'est une console elle fait 39 cm de
haut 10 cm de large et 25 là en
profondeur donc il ya énormément de
meuble télé les niches en fait ça va pas
rentrer ça va pas rentrer dedans
et bien si ça rentre pas de la console
va être beaucoup trop serré à
l'intérieur elle va surchauffée et ça va
être très très mauvais donc je vous
déconseille donc si vous n'avez pas la
place si vous n'avez pas la place dans
le meuble soit vous la mettez à côté de
la télévision
si vous avez un grand meuble de
téléalarme carrément vous la mettez par
terre vous la mettez par terre à côté de
vos meubles télé mais par contre sony
déconseille fortement de la poser par
terre si vous avez de la moquette ou si
vous avez un tapis en fait si vous avez
des fibres qui pourrait rentrer dans le
système de 20 dans le ventilation delà
de la console donc si jamais c'est le
cas peut-être poser
vous avez dû protection une blanche
n'importe quoi pour éviter voilà que ça
rentre en contact qui est des fibres qui
rentre dans votre console
voilà merci à vous êtes plusieurs à nous
avoir rejoints en vous
remercie merci par exemple avouerez
divers qui nous dit que le développement
sur cette console n'est qu'à son début
ça promet j'attends une année pour voir
des jeux encore plus optimisée merci de
votre commentaire
bonsoir l'iace news dm j'espère ne pas
écorcher votre nom vous nous demandez si
on pourra se procurer des consoles en
magasin avant noël la réponse est le
courage de ted s'est levé du courage et
si vous avez ben voilà de la chance
aussi puisque bien il est très compliqué
de sens de se la procurer puisque dès
que les stocks sont réapprovisionnés il
s'épuise en quelques minutes
donc voilà soyez courageux si vous
souhaitez offrir ce cadeau à noël ou
jouglar curé on a alors on a je prends
toutes vos questions et je le répète
n'hésitez pas à les poser à rester avec
nous si on prend un peu de temps allez
allez allez prendre
voilà on essaye de répondre à tout le
monde et de vraiment d'être exhaustif
sur notre reprise de question que ce
soit sur la page principale du figaro
sur youtube ou sur twitter merci en tout
cas d'être d'être avec nous merci de vos
messages aussi très sympathique
notamment des lieders qui nous dit très
sympa ce format je ne savais pas que
figaro parler de jeux vidéo pas si on en
parle depuis très longtemps sachez qu'on
est une petite secte vidéoludique et
cette réaction est qu on a toujours
plaisir voilà faire des contenus vidéo
ludique là le prochain en dot et bien ce
sera le test de cyberpunk je pense sans
trop vous spoiler n'hésitez pas à rester
connectés on vous offrira cela alors
vous parlez du
du caractère stocks dans cette qu'on
serait weinstein qui nous apporte sur un
thème que je connais très bien vu les
plaques blanchâtre qui arbore cette
nouvelle playstation at elle protéger
des balles ou des balles de l bd en
manif et bien écoutez je sais la
manifestation sociale ou dit voilà ce
qui est désigné comme l'appel à la
marche contre les lois liberticides et
bien on se retrouvera pour voir cela
merci en tout cas entertainment et v
merci en tout cas tous vos de nos
salutations bonjour gold silent merci
d'être avec nous et théaux fr merci kisa
mais nous voulons demander ce qu'on
pense des manuels mâcon à écouter à vous
de vous faire une opinion on n'est pas
là pour dire ce qu'on pense du président
encore moins lors de ce test
merci à vous de gold silent vous me
demandez ce qu'est assassin's creed
alors tiens assassin's creed vallat qui
lui est disponible également sur ps 5
oui il relève également son ps5
alors c'est dommage que là ce que la
semaine dernière quand il ya 15 il ya
dix jours quand on a fait le test de la
xbox on a joué à ça c'est parce qu'on
avait la version xbox par contre il
n'est pas la version ps1 je pourrais pas
vous le montrer sur place 5 mai
bassaget que c'est un très bon jeu voilà
je m'amuse beaucoup dessus et voilà donc
là nous sommes dans le nexus
alors voilà z'avez vu que devant le gros
monstre je suis morte c'est fait exprès
c'est normal on est obligé de perdre
devant ce monstre pour arriver dans le
nexus donc vous voyez quand même comme
c'est très très très joli ce jeu est
l'un des très beaux effets de lumière et
c'est ces magnifiques allez je tente le
niveau sur lequel je me suis entraîné
alors en tout cas vous avez un petit fan
club qui est en train de se composer
chloé kraft sur youtube sur twitch sur
la page principale filiale rwe games qui
trouvent que vous vous débrouillez bien
on à elie de beauce qui rêve de pouvoir
jouer au mode zombie de call of duty
voilà bah merci à vous de vos messages
on a aussi une petite pique à notre
consoeur carole quinten h qui vous
trouvent moins mal de cas mais aussi de
vos messages en tout cas acquise à mais
qui le nexus de demon soul que de
souvenirs bah oui on sait c'est un
classique désormais du jeu plus de dix
ans après sa sortie avec ce reboot en
exclu sur ps 5
merci à vous on à force de games qui
nous dit vivement le test de cyberpunk
merci le fic va vivement l'automne moi
j'ai hâte de l'essayer
j'ai hâte qu'ils sortent aussi pour me
procurer ça c'est vraiment une des
attentes qu'on est je pense très
nombreux à avoir depuis plusieurs années
oui et liteo qui nous dit sur twitter
que à une époque il y avait même du jeu
de rôle / sur notre chaîne figurent
livewii tout avec fibres tenir là il y
avait une émission qui s'appelait
premiers rôles ces derniers mois qu'on a
pu vous faire vivre en direct sur
twitter youtube et sur la page
principale du figaro va merci en tout
cas à tous pour vos messages et votre
fidélité ça fait plaisir à voir
merci aussi de vos commentaires
constructifs et intéressante
kisa mais qui dit ce que vous trouvez
que le line up de la psf ne justifie pas
500 euros investis même si le spider man
et demon soul sont bien merci beaucoup
de vos de vaud de vos commentaires ça
fait plaisir
la règle de base vraiment que les
nouvelles consoles c'est qu'on attend
qu'on attend quelques mois on attend
voire parfois même un an avant
d'investir le temps que la qui est des
jeux en fait qui est des choses qui
valent vraiment le coup
alors ça que si vous voulez absolument
jouer à damon soldats ça va être
compliqué de résister mais bon si c'est
m demon's souls et spider man qui laisse
de glace attendait surtout que comme
vous avez dû voir en fait sur les jeux
récents il y en a énormément qui seront
vous aurez droit gratuitement à la
version playstation 5
si vous voulez acheter sur playstation
cadre vous proposera genre vous aurez
look great playstation 5 gratuite donc
vous perdrez pas grand chose si à ce
noël vous avez déjà une playstation 4 où
vous dites bompard dont je jouais à call
of duty ou à ça s'en va à la voulait
acheter sur playstation 4
dans quelques mois quand vous achèterez
votre playstation 5 vous pourrez avoir
gratuitement la mise à jour plus jeunes
sont à la merci de ces précisions qu'il
est bon d'apporter que ce soit pour la
xbox ou pour la paix est 5 c'est vrai
que ben voilà on en est à la naissance
de cette nouvelle
génération de consoles donc à vous
d'estimer quelles sont vos besoins et
vous vos préférences selon à ce que vous
pouvez voir même à travers un autre test
bonsoir terreur monstre 666 en juin sur
youtube merci d'être avec nous bonsoir
bateau serra linux qui nous dit
cela vous intéresserait-il de découvrir
notre projet rétro gaming dans le futur
bah oui tout à fait n'hésitez pas alors
restez connectés
on découvrira sa avec grand plaisir
on peut revenir sur un sujet qu'on a
abordé mais pour idéaux qui nous a posé
une question qu'on avait abordé plus tôt
mais on va le faire pour vous et théo
sur twitch s'il ya du raytracing sur ps5
wii iphone armée ça dépend ça dépend des
jeux voilà ça dépend des jeux et surtout
j'avance ya du ray tracing vous n'aurez
pas de 60 fps
il faut faire faut faire un choix la
console peut pas gérer en tout cas pour
le moment ne peut pas gérer les deux
parce que le ray tracing ça consomme
énormément de mémoire de données etc
donc il peut pas pour le moment les jeux
peuvent pas gérer les deux et la sueur
sur demon's souls ce que je dis pas de
faire voila voila je n importe quoi je
vois pas qu'on fait on m'attaque up mais
là il tourne le jeu tourne à 60 espèces
voilà qui qui vous répond bonsoir à vous
qui l'enjoignait comité eau ou encore
tristan ou encore vous qui avez en
longue je vais prendre plaisir à lire en
entier joueur n cadeaux sniper canon
orbitale tikhonov du 78 bien évidemment
merci d'être avec nous merci d'être
toujours avec nous baba
ou encore vous même
h également merci à tous chine mais
également stif leurs 95 également vous
ne dites personnellement la xbox pour
vous et dix fois mieux merci de partager
votre avis tiens on a une question de
chine mais chloé sur le casque pulse
qu'en pensez-vous utile ou useless
alors je ne vais pas essayer
personnellement mais des tests que j'ai
vu voir il disait que c'était pas mal
mais bon si vous avez votre propre
casque audio
ça fait tout à fait ça fait le job comme
diraient nos amis nos amis québécois
bonsoir à vous sur la page principale du
figaro je vous retrouve nico 0,09
merci également chris kraus qu'on a
plaisir à retrouver très régulièrement
qu'ils étaient avec nous ce matin je
crois déjà pour les déclarations du
gouvernement au sujet de
l'assouplissement du confinement
merci d'être avec nous alors on a déjà
une question de nico 009 une question
qui nous est déjà parvenu tout à l'heure
mais qui est qui est intéressante alors
économique qui serait pas mal répondre
aux questions et excusez nous mais vous
avez également aux couples fois sur la
page principale du figaro sur youtube et
sur twitch on essaie vraiment de
répondre à tout le monde
nico 09 qui nous demandent si les
batteries des manettes tiennent plus
longtemps que sur ps4 c'est vrai qu'on
n'a pas abordé ce thème encore alors
pour le moment oui mais après bas comme
vous savez en plus et utilisez vos
batteries plus elles vont s'user
moi j'avoue que sur playstation 4 j'ai
été chanceuse mais mes batteries ont
plutôt bien plus dans le temps mais je
sais qu'il ya des gens pour qui ben
voila l oms
sa fille est très vite donc essayer d'en
prendre soin de prendre soin de vos
aulas de prendre soin de vos batteries
de ne pas laisser tout en vous vos
manettes branché
et après c'est de faire vivre le plus le
plus longtemps possible mais je suis
content de voir chris goss qui nous
demande et c'est vrai que c'est une très
bonne question à l'heure actuelle est ce
que ça vaut encore le coup d'acheter une
ps4 pro ou une ps4
bah moi je trouvais ça un petit peu un
petit peu dommage
enfin même si vous allez avoir de quoi
vous amuser en si vous vous lancez
seulement dans la playstation 4
parce que là parce que il ya énormément
de jeu mais après ce qui est chouette
avec la décéption 5 alors ça ne sera pas
le même prix mais si vous vous abonnés
au playstation plus donc il ya un
abonnement qui est indispensable pour
jouer en ligne sony va vous offrir une
vingtaine de jeux playstation 4
et elles ce sont des jeux playstation
cadre d' une très très bonne qualité
d'une excellente qualité de genres très
différents
non ce qui est bien pour les gens qui
n'ont pas eu la playstation casse alors
par est de refaire un petit peu leur
retard
voilà pour vous répondre je vois
beaucoup de commentaires et de questions
merci d'être avec nous en tout cas et
merci de passer ce test avec nous alors
je vais essayer de prendre vos questions
va rebondir sur ce commentaire de
christian schneuwly ne vaut-il mieux pas
attendre la venue du ps -cinq slim avec
un blu ray en noir ce serait le rêve ici
d'ici un ou deux ans bah oui c'est je
vois en tout cas aussi de nouveaux
arrivants alors on va s'orienter vers la
fin de ce stream ça fait un peu plus
d'une heure et demi que nous sommes bons
diables déjà et c'est bien si ça passe
vite c'est que ça fait plaisir de passer
du temps avec vous bonsoir avant-garde
qui nous a rejoints sur youtube merci
toujours triste en chine mais vern
cotten motivés qu'ils avaient kisame
pardon et joueurs mk2 un départ canon
orbitale qui coule objets 78 merci
d'être avec nous alors pour répondre
avant de prendre vos questions moi
j'avais une question qui rebondit sur le
nom même de ready vr je sais que la ps
qu'elle disposait d'un casque vr que la
presse 5 dispose de ce type aux
disposant a plutôt je crois de son
casque vr comment ça se passe bien pour
le moment va-t-on sait pas grand chose
si vous avez un casque playstation vers
vous pouvez demander un sony s'il ya un
formulaire à remplir en ligne qui vous
envoie un adaptateur pour vous visiez
continuer à utiliser votre casque
playstation 4 sur la playstation 5
par contre pour la suite des événements
sony dit enfin le président de
playstation dit oui on fera des choses
sont on croit toujours la guerre il y
aurait des choses en vr ne sera pas
l'année prochaine ce sera pas l'année
suivante
donc attendez pas grand chose avant 2023
voilà donc c'est pas très très clair si
c'est vraiment ce qui va vraiment
continuer à soutenir la verse et je
pense que ça n'a pas non plus obtenu le
résultat qu'ils attendaient c'est ce
thème
alors est ce que je vais bien qu'une à
la réalisation vous pourriez faire
plaisir avant garde et nous montrer
quelques plans de ce fps 5
voilà pour vous répondre
regarde vous demandiez à quoi elle
ressemble bien c'est un beau bébé
les yankees loi qui est donc
littéralement plus lourd que certains
bébés humains
1 voilà en tout cas pour vous répondre
avant garde on peut répondre également
alors j'essaye de vous retrouver puisque
ça défile beaucoup tristan qui revient
sur la manette on me dit que la manette
ps 1 qui est vraiment incroyable
laisserai pas écouté c'est pas à nous de
dire si elle est incroyable en tout cas
elle dispose de capacités fort
prometteuse avec un retour de force et
plein de nouvelles capacités que nous
disons ne disposez pas la dualshock là
on parle de la dual sense c'est le
modèle qui est sorti pour cette ps5
voilà on a on avait une question aussi
je vais essayer de vous vous retrouvez
alors là on en effet ça défile
voilà merci en tout cas de votre message
anti elie de vos skis madone qui
m'adresse un big up ça fait toujours
plaisir je vois beaucoup de questions
alors en ce qui concerne le lecteur
blu-ray chloé est ce que vous avez pu le
tester pour les films la 4k
non non j'ai pas mis de famille de films
blu ray par contre voir soyez au courant
que quand vous mettrez un disque dans le
lecteur ça fait un petit peu de bruit ça
fait un petit peu de riz notamment
démarrage donc ça peut surprendre parce
que ça fait vraiment de manière assez
voilà très belles imitations dit oui
c'est un petit peu un petit peu fort
mais bon c'est juste le temps que le
disque se lance après ça ça se calme pas
mal de questions en ce qui concerne
l'adaptation des casques audio sur la
ps1 qu est ce qu un peu par exemple
brancher des via bluetooth des casques
audio différents de ce qui est proposé
par fait la ps1 alors je crois que
je vais pas dire bêtises mais il sent
qu'il ya des petits fruits avec les
casques bluetooth sur la ps -cinq donc
opté plutôt si vous abusez des casques
filaires
il suffit de les brancher directement
sur votre manette et c'est le bonheur
mais je crois oui tous les casques
bluetooth ne sont pas compatibles avec
la concept merci à vous de nous
rejoindre sur youtube notamment bonsoir
romain veeckman ce je vais également me
rien vers la page principale du figaro
avec kriss kross qui est toujours avec
nous qu'on remercie je vois je vois vos
commentaires vous nous dites que vous
c'est la taille qui vous rebute je vous
n'avez pas la place ou alors il faut
changer de meubles tv
bah oui c'est vrai que on a pu le voir
elle est particulièrement imposante et
là bas au delà d'avoir les moyens en
tout cas de pouvoir se la procurer il
faut aussi avoir les moyens matériels de
pouvoir l'accueillir chez soi à la fois
de façon sécurisée pour pas qu'elle
s'abîme mais aussi tout simplement de
pouvoir l'accueillir la c1 c'est un
meuble à part entière quasiment voilà en
tout cas sur sur cet aspect de la
console qui qui a marqué beaucoup
beaucoup n'étaient pas fan d'ailleurs
quand on te l'a été
le design divisant c'est vraiment la
victoire de vouloir voilà en tout cas
pour vous répondre allez on va
s'orienter
d'ici quelques minutes à la fin de ce
live merci d'être avec nous alors pour
vous répondre aux mânes romain rysman ce
sur la taille de la paix à 5 alors je
sais qu'elle pèse 4,5 kg cependant des
détails sur sa dimension à la livre à
une meuf je les connais par coeur
maintenant 39 cm de haut
26 cm de profondeur 10 cm de hauteur
voilà qui vous répond c'est
excessivement merci pour votre message
for the games a fait plaisir sur twitch
et d'ailleurs je vous ai pas remercier
vous êtes plusieurs à vous être avoir
follow la chaîne twitch kenan qui est
avec nous tout à l'heure pour des ricoh
merci beaucoup on a eu veine ex
également qu'ils à fall au mazembe
merci beaucoup du follow ça fait très
plaisir et n'hésitez pas à rejoindre
notre petite communauté dont fait partie
l entertainment et v depuis la dernière
année un ca fait plaisir
et merci également la régie comme le
soutien fort de game merci à juniac
chainel à la réalisation qui a géré
l'organisation et là réalisation de cela
et vallées on va se quitter
je vous remercie on va rester encore
ensemble une ou deux minutes le temps de
se dire au revoir mais merci en tout cas
sur twitch ventotene tv for the games on
perd on byron peut-être chine mais
pour derrick ou sur twitter on a
également fernandez fernandez sébastien
merci à romain avec man avant garde et
devos bien évidemment merci sur la page
principale du figaro à kriss kross qui
nous dit sinon les jeux ont l'air super
mais est-ce révolutionnaire par rapport
à la ps4
on voit vraiment le gap technologique ou
pas je pense pas qu'on puisse dire qu'à
cette génération de jeux et de consoles
on le voit on on voit un gap aussi
important que pour les différences entre
les prétendants une façon j'arrive tout
le temps va passer - laisse aux
technologies vont être immenses fin je
pense qu on revivra pas quelque chose
aussi dingue que du passage pas juste de
la 2d à la 3d pour les gens les plus
âgés présents ici qui ont vécu ça qu'ils
sont passés bas de la super nintendo à
la playstation 1 ça a été juste une
révolution copernicienne fin c'était
c'était absolument dingue on sentait
qu'on passe dans une autre galaxie
la non enfin le saut est petit même si
ce sont quand même enfin là moi je vois
que le jeu se démène sol c'est
extrêmement fins extrêmement détaillé il
est rapide au niveau du framerate
enfin on sent qu'on a gagné en qualité
après c'est sûr que si pardon jeudi à
vienne playstation 4 pro vous allez voir
la marche va être plus petit
moi j'avais une playstation 4 classique
bon je sens qu'il ya quand même une
marche technologique qui a été franchi
mais si vous aviez à playstation 4 trop
basse c'est une demie marchand fait que
vous allez vous allez franchir dans sa
tête - whaou
mais oui c'est en fait je crois que ses
consoles se différencie surtout sur leur
praticité sur le ssd en fait sur le fait
qu'elle soit beaucoup plus rapide c'est
c'est ça en fait pour moment les gains
sont là dessus après les sont en
consoles fin souvenez vous des premiers
jeux playstation 4
il n'était pas aussi magnifique que les
jeux de playstation 4 à la toute fin
enfin il n'y avait pas de the last hope
us 2 à la sortie en 2013 sur la
playstation 4 c'est pareil pour toutes
les générations de consoles donc là les
son temps pour que les développeurs
vraiment se saisissent au maximum des
capacités de la console
et voilà ce que je pense qu'on le
so on le verra dans quelques années
voilà en tout cas bien pour clôturer
pour rappel c'est la ps 5 le dernier né
de sony c'est à 399 euros si vous prenez
la digital editions sans lecteur de cd
donc c'est à 499 euros si vous souhaitez
avoir le lecteur c'est en rupture de
stock
bien évidemment tout comme sa
concurrente xbox ça pèse 4,5 kg c'est à
ces subventions s'approprier une manette
qui propose beaucoup de nouvelles
compétences qui s'appelle la durolle
sense avec une retraite rétro
compatibilité limitée au jeu de la ps4
voilà sinon ben voila ca propose des des
compétences comme le raytracing ou le
ssd comme vous l'avez si bien expliqué
voilà en tout cas pour faire un petit
récapitulatif
merci une dernière fois à vous furent
d'eric ou sur twitter chinois sur
youtube entertainment tv sur twitch elie
de vaux sur youtube
merci également à tristan idéaux
ite ofr gaga rulfo 72 merci à kriss
kross sur la page principale du figaro
également à
benjamin lui inscrit à lindu 57 nathan
0,06 voilà et bien l'heure est venue
pour moi de vous souhaiter une très
bonne soirée vidéoludique encore merci
chloé merci à merci à vous écouter je
suis personnellement plutôt ravi de ne
pas être maître humilié sur demon's
souls
oui d'ailleurs beaucoup de beaucoup
d'internautes
beaucoup d'internautes vous remercie
alors oui théo je vous vois les
personnes avancent vous voit pas en
temps normal mais nous gardons une
prestation bien sûr mais en tout cas
merci pour cela et vous avez eu un
succès dans votre compétence
demon soul est ce qu'avec beaucoup
d'internautes qui ont qui ont souligné
et ont remarqué que vous étiez plutôt
bien débrouillé à écouter j'en profite
pour remercier mon mari qui m'a entraîné
moines sol flore week-end dernier pour
que je ne sois pas trop ridicule pour ce
live donc mathieu si tu me regardes
merci à toi de m'avoir m'avoir entraîné
et voilà donc c'est pour ça maintenant
je sais qu'il faut faire des roulades
qu'il faut utiliser sa quête elle touche
donc sinon je pense que si je n'avais
pas eu cet entraînement sera était
absolument terrible voilà big up à
mathieu on vous remercie je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée et on se
dit à très bientôt pour de nouveaux
stream sur figaro live